sometimes i feel the necessity to uh to
point out things that are happening on
uh on tiktok mainly because this is the
stuff your kids actually watch
so i was confronted yesterday on twitter
with a bizarre tic toc video
about a phenomenon called libra gender
now you may be confused at this point
because you're a rational and sentient
human being
and it is strange that every two seconds
somebody is coming up with a new gender
of course that's not strange at all
given the basis of gender theory which
is that gender is completely mutable and
also is a complete spectrum
it goes all the way from heterosexual
total heterosexuality on one side all
the way to homosexuality on the other
side anything in between you could be
agender
right that's that's regard to sexual
orientation gender or that sexual
orientation is a spectrum according to
the left so is gender right there's male
on one side female on the other and then
all the in-betweens and in the dead
center would be agender which is a
person without a gender which is weird
it's like a kendall
which is smooth where there should
actually be protrusions apparently okay
so now we have the phenomenon of libra
gender now if you're wondering what is
libra gender
let me play you this video in which a
tick tock girl explains libra gender hey
guys let's talk gender specifically
libra genders firstly know the
difference between a static or a stable
gender one that doesn't change and a
fluid gender one that does change now
libra genders liber gender people feel
mostly agender with a slight connection
to another gender firstly libra feminine
and i do want you guys to keep in mind
for the rest of the video that there is
another black line down there feminine
people feel mostly agender and slightly
feminine describe it as feeling a strong
connection to a gender as well as a
lesser connection to femininity super
masculine is the opposite where someone
feels mostly agender and slightly
masculine described as having a strong
connection to being genderless as well
as a lesser connection to being
masculine lastly we have libra fluid
zebrafluid people feel mostly agender
with a slight connection to another
gender that fluctuates throughout other
genders stay with me here they feel a
strong connection to being agender and
another part of their gender feels fluid
one part will always feel asian or the
other part will fluctuate between
masculine and feminine hope that could
help
that didn't help
so um just want to point out that your
kids actually watch this crap and then
they start to believe that you can
identify as libra gender which if i get
this right means that you mostly feel
connected to agender which is weird i'm
not sure how you'd feel connected to
that but you feel connected to having no
gender which is literally impossible
because all human beings are sexually
dichotomous right you're either you're
we are a sexually dimorphic species
you're either male or you're a female
there are a few people who have
unfortunate conditions that make them
intersex that is not what she is talking
about she's talking about how you
identify as a biological male or a
biological female as agender
which presumably means that you just
stand there right you don't manifest any
actual activity because it could be
masculine and then but libra gender is
not just agender
it's agender with a slight hint with
just a dollop of masculinity or
femininity
it's like coffee with a little bit of
sugar um
so i have a proposal here
and it it's out of left field so stick
with me here
here's the proposal the proposal is that
if gender is a complete spectrum and if
every individual
has their own specific gender right
because you could be
libra gender
you could be libra fluid you could be
again get this straight or not so
straight you could be 53.3 agender
you could simultaneously also be 27.7
feminine but at the same exact time you
could be 19 masculine
you never know you could be all of these
things at once
according to these folks and you can and
it could be fluid right those
percentages could shift
but sometimes you could feel like a
unicorn and sometimes you could feel
like a horse but you really don't need
to to specify on any given day
we all have to have our own labels right
and each each
time those percentages shift the label
shifts
so i have a proposal instead of using
these labels which are very very
confusing and each require their own how
about this
we call you
by a name
your name we could say
jill and just for purposes of clarity so
that we know who you are because jill
you know names could be asexual
just for purposes of clarity we call you
by your biological sex which is
perfectly objectively verifiable by
outsiders so instead of saying
here is a person who is libra gender
2.3 percent
feminine
and
97.7 percent agender we would just say
you are
a biological woman named jill
you with me it's even more specific than
what you're trying to do
i i know this is revolutionary stuff try
to wrap your mind around it though it
might be useful in the future
who's got two thumbs and wants you to
like and subscribe